[Música]
Era una noche festiva en el club q Un
refugio para la comunidad lgbt de
Colorado Springs estaban conmemorando el
20 de noviembre Día del Recuerdo
transgénero cuando cada año se hace un
homenaje a las personas trans asesinadas
en plena fiesta irrumpió una persona
armada y disparó
cuando salí había cuerpos en el piso
había vidrios rotos vasos rotos gente
llorando
[Aplausos]
el sospechoso fue identificado como
Anderson lealdrick de 22 años dos
personas lo redujeron y evitaron que
pudiera continuar matando el club q los
llamó héroes en un comunicado y así lo
vivió uno de sus camareros
mi primer pensamiento en lo que no puedo
dejar de pensar es en las imágenes de la
noche de los cuerpos de la sangre de los
vidrios rotos de la carnicería y los
escombros y ver un lugar seguro
convertido en una zona de guerra
el ataque más mortal después del 11 de
septiembre de 2021 fue en 2016 en una
discoteca lgbti de Orlando cuando 49
personas fueron asesinadas según
estadísticas oficiales Estados Unidos
vive un resurgimiento de ataques contra
personas transgénero el presidente Joe
biden se solidarizó y debemos eliminar
las desigualdades que contribuyen a la
violencia contra las personas lgbtq y
más no podemos tolerar el odio en el
debate los ataques contra personas lgbti
pero también el uso de armas Estados
Unidos ha vivido 600 un tiroteos en lo
que va de año en un país que tiene más
armas que habitantes y en el que 49.000
personas murieron por heridas de bala en
2021 una cifra récord